my name is Courtney Raj and the advocacy
director for the Committee to Protect
Journalists and international press
freedom watchdog so press freedom really
depends on the ability of the press to
report freely and independently and when
you have a verdict like this it scares
other journalists and so it can cause
self-censorship it can cause a chilling
effect where perhaps international
journalists might not feel like going
into Egypt anymore journalists working
in Egypt will not feel that they are
able to do their jobs or freely report
it certainly it has happened in other
countries we see that anti state charges
and anti terrorism charges are often
used as a way to imprison journalists
this journalists who are imprisoned are
often have used that don't align with
the people in power our opposition
voices or dissident voices and we see
the same thing in Egypt we see this in
Ethiopia we see it in Iran which are
among the leading Taylor of journalists
of Turkey and no recently was also
jailing a lot of journalists and so this
is really problematic because what that
indication is that these journalists are
being imprisoned because they don't
adhere to the people in power right so
they're not adhering to the line of
those who are power but one of the key
roles of journalists system features to
power and to really hold leaders
accountable and so it's incredibly
problematic when they get jailed because
that sends a really chilling message to
anyone else who would engage in
independent reporting
you